olá eu sou o jornal último e não bebo há
três dias e voltar vou tirar os sapatos
porque era só pra fazer bonito eu mostro
mas de forte sol o caminho ao sentir
confortáveis e já agora todos alguns
truques de televisão nós quando fazemos
diretos
estamos sempre assim a oposição diz ter
cuidado vocês choram vendo aqui pra cima
não é que nós estamos assim quer pré
quer como não nos fugir não é um dos
inscritos que vocês ficam a saber e é a
primeira vez que estou descalça no boxe
um pouco já neste jovem mais crônico
eu não sou do fotojornalista mais séria
do universo lingüístico português só
talvez já e os imensos hoje com
explicações à minha pessoa no facebook
na rua no twitter e em todo lado as duas
dizem grande maluca
não sou bastante saudável do ponto de
vista psicológico estou aqui
profissionais que vão fazer essa
avaliação de forma mais aguda mas mas tô
sou uma pessoa normal e o que eu faço
num vórtice momento a sério por isso que
é um crime em portugal não é tão gostosa
como dizia o homem que esteve aqui antes
de mim
curiosamente eu tivemos um padrão crente
eu sou agnóstica já agora também gosta
de afirmar o meu partido que é o
agnosticismo muito normal
vou dar um exemplo da minha normalidade
é eu trabalho em televisão às vezes as
pessoas têm alguma tem alguma atenção
virada pra mim por causa do meu trabalho
e às vezes convidado para fazer aquelas
produções mais vistas em tal agora vamos
lá ver jornal 'the na ilha de caras com
seus filhos e seu marido não o latino
vai fazer
são fotográfica que é o que ela leva
objetivo um shot luta é que os moção a
atenção é que os seus a parte de
borracha que até chorou porque eu acho
que depois quiserem passar a favor dele
eu até posso chutar tipo você chegar e
se quiserem conhecer entretendo enquanto
possa tirar poder chegar forte ao mesmo
destino os botões eu faça o favor podem
cheirar
peço que você entender quanto eu vou
falando aqui se não tiverem 70 mil só
país e parece um caso fictício não é pra
não fui comer chocolate no motel
não fui com o seu apetite de carlina era
não sei que fui de calções com uma coisa
que por ser mais ou menos uns tido
pediram para fazer pose para foto e
aconteceu isto
e de facto foi esta fotografia foi
publicada e factos quando uma pessoa
está a falar-se ok isso o jornalista
escutou uma portagem super série que eu
fiz sete episódios de 15 minutos sobre
os bastidores da ficção nacional em
portugal
largamente elogiada pela crítica uma
coisa seriíssima contrário do que
costuma fazer e como é que eu promovo
meu trabalho
assim você consegue parar até que até um
chumbo do meu vento que se vê na
fotografia
não é preciso ir ao photoshop já para
não falar do windows vânia setal e e
pronto que eu também não sou eu não é
que as pessoas de visão sentiu assim eu
não estou a dizer isso mas eu não me
sinto como não irão tomar um comprimido
de total nem do 'povo crônicas como usar
sou uma rapariga de facto querem
desconstruir a e o trio tem muito eu
considero um aprofundamento sortuda
porque porque apesar de eu ser
completamente formatada não fechar a
tampa toda história sempre fora do
quadrado vi tudo e mais alguma coisa tem
que ter muita sorte porque na escola uma
das pessoas que falam da manhã falou do
problema da escola na escola sempre
compreender o fato de eu ser formatada e
de escola e na universidade por
universidade foi uma aluna vilks porque
não conseguia decorar e 300 páginas
manuais de 1968 daninhas péssima tipo
foram conseguia ii a páginas tantas na
minha vida depois de uma passagem rápida
pela rádio e fui parar na televisão
porque alguém acho que foi no santos que
eu faria sentimento visão eu até me
lembro de ir à entrevista com ele
perguntar
serys se olha pra mim vai hoje até tocou
é mais compostas imprevisto até passava
na televisão mas eu tenho uma camisola
do super-homem com símbolo do super
homem estava com os calções e umas botas
daquelas tipo bloco martins pretas de
salvar uma fita cor rosa na cabeça nunca
pensei que o fato de que eu fosse uma
entrevista a sério e eu fui para a
televisão tem que fazer algum esforço
para me adaptar a um mike tem de facto
muitas regras mexe
deixei sempre uma marca eo que estava
deixando a mensagem pra todos vocês que
estão mais novos mais velhos já vai
começar aqui agora eu acho que passar
por aqui
já tivemos várias teorias agora nestas
primeiras palestras da tarde sobre o que
é que nós qual é o nosso papel na vida
se a ser felizes e afirmamos o que é que
é
eu acho que é não passaram despercebidas
noé mesmo cria um fosso anos é com toda
a discrição mas temos que ser nós
próprios e eu pude muito que eu sou na
televisão o que eu proponho agora é que
fechamos a minha peça mais séria de
todas
qual é o pan se de instrumento jornal
este uma a não ser que peço sanchuri da
viação costa de portimão e os 6 mi
fui ao game março na mídia new york
vamos lá gravas a fúria e deixou o mogi
mirim por 2 a 1 em 1 hora e 41 no aek
stone volta
tóquio 25 pode estar
joão moutinho ao clicrbs mel e ao top
por causa do mundo
ok é ótimo ter tantos aplausos nesta
sala porque o que aconteceu nos segundos
que seguiram a exibição desta peça no
jornal da noite da sic foi um massacre
joana o time feriu de morte o jornalismo
português
ela veio retirar a secretária
profissional ela havia ser expulsa da
sic quem eu volte mão pra deixar aquela
criatura fazer dois minutos e meio
provisão ao cairo
quem são estas pessoas criticam isto
consegue imaginar não vi aquilo remédios
só usar não sair não são os próprios
jornalistas
os próprios jornalistas é minha classe
os meus colegas de ti estarão esta minha
peça mas estarão porque é perguntar eu e
meu filho aqui algum princípio de ontem
lógico ou ético eu os fatos não estão lá
o que aconteceu aqui onde aquino onde é
que esta peça não tem onde como quando
porque quem cai
estou lá eu certo é o jornalista não é
notícia o jornalista é sério não estar
sóbrio jornalista fala tudo conseguir
dar porque os assuntos sérios que tanto
podia ter feito esta pensa assim está em
portugal deve dar seu a fluir ói das
férias dos anos 80 e 90 angela merkel
chamou o kit em caso de justiça jairo e
marés vivas vovó mas existe tal coisa de
um olha tu visão que faz com que ninguém
olhe para o que está a passar na
televisão e eu na minha loucura
desenvolveu uma teoria muito própria
aqui há uns anos que já só tem três
minutos em maio fish e não pessoas meus
netos que não se costuma ser mais ou
menos isso pra mim e isso é que é o
verdadeiro e chorei isso não é nada é um
prazer estar aqui com vocês e adorava
que você não fizer assim mas as
perguntas mas isto infelizmente
unilateral
se quiserem no fiofó com toda a gente
você já não é o que eu fiz então a
partir de determinado momento da minha
vida foi chegar à conclusão de que
improvisam nós temos que ser
em comunicação em geral captadores de
atenção não é nós temos que ter uma
faísca qualquer porque o que passa na
televisão não seja tudo igual não é
as medidas são todas boas chances de
giro e chutou duas magras
os homens junto cheiros têm duas vezes
impagáveis gravatas agora fininhas
náutico concentraram largas e as riscas
como só usa agora do cd s
meu e hoje é vedado pires lima grande
cómico é esse semestre maravilhoso
festejo giro ele apresentava assim não
pode sempre gente possa também poderão
porém uma música e bailado que fazer
também vai não
tanto é que eu acho eu acho que o jornal
ritmo ser sério não tem nada a ver com
não utilizar um novo sentido de humor
que é uma coisa nós estamos sempre
prontos para rir não é verdade é tão
fácil que ir eu estive a ver vos ouvir
sobretudo a olhar pra minha peça e de
fato você estão à espera do momento
prefiro é bom rir e vanilla mais uma
coisinha pra rir não é porque o peso do
limão é que o filme seria entregue no
parlamento o homem péssima noite com
este time e distribui vagas para ser
gravada e vai perturbar não vou dizer
que o que eu realmente peso é um amor
o senhor mas que ela não tem muito
sentido stop google não é porque vai
propor um momento fazer aquelas cenas
votos tendo up comedy que o fecha e
esperam ser levado a sério
ou seja para docs não é afinal o perdoe
mas é imensa piada e eu imagino está
cheio de humor ditou a critical não o
que eu quero dizer é que nós só temos
que falar sobre isso não é um e rico e
temos que expor não tenho as coisas
estão mesmo à mão será em proibir noé
o que é que se passou quando vai vir a
ser um novo em portugal eu pensei ok com
erros serviço é o que o próprio vik na
peça não é todos nós hoje não sei se a
toda a gente se lembra destas duas
séries ou não
mais ou menos
na senhora ó não ok as suas mais
pequeninos não é
os bébés pronto mas os bebês não podiam
não viu o primeiro entrar aqui porque
estas políticas têm bolinha vermelha não
tem nada a não ser que ligam a proposta
não é inconstitucional e simplesmente
proteger a bola
isto por dizer o que eu acho que de fato
é nós chamamos rir de nós próprios foi
uma coisa que eu acho que não vamos
muito aqui é o principal
e eu acho que falta em portugal eu estou
falando especificamente da vila
portuguesa porque é onde o movimento e
como eu não faço força um pouco pra pôr
as pessoas em geral uma coisa é não sair
eu sou um carinho assim faltam 31 50
quando eu chegar a 0 c loja e sair assim
confetes e coisas e chocolate solitário
de marfim é uma história cheia de
contato com eles e eu faço o foco muita
confusão nós não saibamos fazer esse
exercício do autor foi exceção e nos
rirmos de nós próprios o procon salva
com alguém lá fora já a romã que foi
sobre aquela história nós nos rimos
quando alguém cai eo isso não faço vou
correr ajudar a pessoa exatamente eu rio
é quando eu caio quando eu caio e por se
ver a cena fora
não é por desconforto ou por nada vc é
porque eu consigo ser mim olhar
prostituição sair eu não me guay estou
vivo e tem a sua piada não é
vou contar até seu falecimento o peso
que uma pessoa tem mesmo tipo sentido de
humor que eu tinha uns tirinhos importem
não tenham os saltos altos começo quando
praia passear mas não tiravam também
sair num café nenhuma deveria continuar
nada víamos os lotes porque é que
aconteça joana os governantes que é uma
coisa que eu faço pelo menos uma vez por
ano às vezes por coisas desta vez não
condicionada
claro que tudo o que fez e viu minha
roupa interior e minha suíte pelo menos
a parte boss quem como ele fez ressaltou
gênita do enem levantou o melhor de tudo
isso foi cordial mas acho que não disse
neves fisichella e eudes processos que
estavam à volta e eu acho que sou e como
rittel é um lamentável
cada um sabe como quer
pronto o desafio que o baixo é que toda
a gente que deixem porque as notícias
são todas as péssimas e horríveis já
ouvi que várias vezes ao longo do dia
criticar supor que o bis aos telejornais
já não vejo notícias que levou o rival
santo andré tenta maior bloco com
vontade de rir não é tem também
desmontar um teve em vocês próprios é é
que o que estou a passar e lembra se que
numa hora e meia do jornal se calhar
dois minutos e mais são meus e vocês
vamos rir com certeza
obrigada